when avengers endgame hits theaters
everyone's going to be gunning for
Thanos and it's hard to think of a
character who has a bigger score to
settle with the mad Titan than Thor
here's how the god of thunder could get
his revenge and take down Panos once and
for all everyone in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe or at least the half of it that
was still breathing after the end of
infinity war has a pretty good reason
for wanting Bannos dead for Thor though
it goes beyond just saving the world
this time
Thanos made it personal the very first
thing we see Thetas do in infinity war
is obliterate most of the remaining us
Guardians
it's especially heartbreaking after the
character arc that ran through thor
ragnarok a film that despite its comedic
moments was at heart about Thor learning
to let go of his father of his hammer
and even if asked art itself which he
destroyed in order to stop hella the
only consolation was the lesson that he
learned from these trials Osgood as well
people stopped even though
right now those people need your help
and now many of those people are dead
including Loki the brother that he was
just starting to get along with again
that's the kind of trauma that results
in a lot of anger and forth or intense
anger tends to end with someone getting
hit very very hard we don't know how
long the gap is between the end of
infinity war and the beginning of
endgame but judging by the trailers
Thor's had plenty of time to rest up do
some push-ups and rethink his strategy
of course that still pits him against
the guy who managed to almost
effortlessly take out the Hulk which is
pretty impressive
after all Hulk's the strongest Avenger
right welcome strongest Avenger Oh what
well not quite in the big fight that
they have in the grandmasters
gladiatorial games Thor is well on his
way to a lightening powered knockout
victory the only reason he loses is due
to interference from the Grandmaster
himself of course if this battle
happened in a movie with Hulk's name in
the title instead of Thor's we might
have seen a different outcome but still
the fact that he could level the Hulk
with a single punch even without his
hammer shows just how much force Thor is
capable of delivering Thor and Thanos
are both known by their signature
weapons unfortunately for Thanos we see
at the end of infinity war that the
Infinity Gauntlet is burnt out from its
infamous finger snap that's the
situation that Thor is all too familiar
with himself for ages he wielded the
mighty Mjolnir unfortunately it was
destroyed in Ragnarok when hella
fulfilled the prophecies of the early
90s and put a stop to hammer time the
good news
Thor got a brand new mallet called storm
breaker and from what we can tell it's
an improvement in addition to having all
of the original male nears mystical
properties Stormbreaker also allows Thor
to teleport across the galaxy by
controlling the Bifrost Plus the back
half is an axe so you know it can cut
things you can't really do that with a
hammer for anyone else taking
Stormbreaker to the chest would be a
finishing blow for Thanos it's the setup
for a one-liner
have gone for the head it's certainly a
badass moment for the villain but it
also raises a pretty important question
why didn't Thor go for the head he's a
seasoned warrior who has smashed his way
through an army of fire giants and he
knows how to take someone out if he
needs why would he even take the chance
in the movie that fatal mistake happens
because Thor is so consumed by his
desire for revenge but it's easy to see
this as the kind of memorable line that
begs for a callback if Thor gets another
shot it's pretty easy to imagine he
takes Thanos as advice to heart and just
decapitates him without a word after all
he's done it before
in the comics Thanos has been defeated
before and even died a couple of times
none of those losses however have been
quite as bone-crushing lee brutal as the
one that Thor handed to him back in 2000
in a story from Thor number 25 Thanos
has turned his power-hungry attention to
a handful of mystical artifacts the
illumination stone the chalice of ruins
and the math of all ending altogether
they give him the power to potentially
end all existence things do not look
good and just like we saw in the films
round one ends with Thor on the losing
side but that's not where the fight
ended door makes a comeback over the
course of a six-page slugfest and winds
up beating Thanos down with mill near
over and over until the mad Titan can't
even stand up let alone conquer the
universe it's almost enough to make you
feel bad for the bad guys almost there
was one other additional factor at play
though in addition to his signature
hammer
Thor's last-minute comeback was aided by
a new set of magic weaponry of his own
and it just so happens that a few
weapons like that already exist in the
MCU Norse mythology has plenty of
intensely destructive magical weapons
including gun near the spear of Odin the
nearly invulnerable destroyer armor and
the Megane gourd a magical belt that can
double Thor's strength we even know
exactly where that one is we just got a
load Tony don't
sir armor prototype for Cap's new shield
and the making the met the Thor's magic
belt sure most Asgardian weapons were
probably destroyed along with a scart
itself at the end of Ragnarok but it's
just as likely that they were scattered
around the universe waiting for someone
to gather them up if things are as
desperate as they seem from all that sad
music in the end game trailer it might
be time for Thor to gear up and go get
revenge fantasy is the kind of threat
that requires you to pull out all the
stops and it sure does help if all the
stops includes a magic spear that will
never miss its target check out what our
newest video is right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
Marvel characters are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the belt so you don't miss a single one
[Music]